i think you're seeing that big tech and
big government are all for censoring
people and it's not just censoring mean
scary people who happen to be orange or
are named alex jones it's it's anyone
right this andrew tate story it's anyone
who's just saying something that might
put a little power back into your hand
that's what they are going for well how
long has this been going on well this is
this is really extraordinary the daily
caller uh got some info here on the
close relationship between mark
zuckerberg of facebook and dr anthony
fauci mr science facebook founder mark
zuckerberg gave dr anthony fauci his
personal cell phone number in march of
2020 before facebook began censoring
alleged misinformation about the covet
19 pandemic new court documents reveal
documents revealed during the discovery
had shed new light on the biden
administration's role in social media
censorship during the pandemic
zuckerberg's move to give fauci his
phone number demonstrated the intention
to have further communications according
to the plaintiffs in a suit against
president joe biden regarding censorship
of information during the pandemic so
what's really fascinating about this
we're going to show you just a second is
as you know uh over the last couple
weeks mark zuckerberg went on rogan he
went on rogan and admitted that they
censored things related to the hunter
biden story so do you think when he gave
fouchy his number in march of 2020 that
was the beginning of this whole thing do
you think some texts were sent back and
forth do you think he liked being
buddies with the guy who is the truth he
is the truth he is the science and maybe
started doing things on his platform
that would make him and the government
happy rather than doing what was
truthful and honest well in case you
forgot how he is a big fan of censorship
here is zuckerberg on rogan talking
about hunter biden like there was a lot
of attention on twitter
during the election because of the
hunter biden laptop story the new year
yeah so you guys censored that as well
so we took a different path than twitter
um i mean basically the background here
is the fbi i think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um
just so you know like you should be on
high alert there was
we we thought there was a lot of russian
propaganda in the 2016 election we have
it on notice that basically there's
about to be some kind of dump of of um
that's similar to that so just be
vigilant so our protocol is different
from twitter's what twitter did is they
said you can't share this at all um we
didn't do that what we do is we have um
if something is reported to us as
potentially
um misinformation important
misinformation we we also have this
third-party fact-checking program
because we don't want to be deciding
what's true and false and
for the
i think it was
five or seven days when it was basically
being
um
being determined whether it was false
um
the distribution on facebook was
decreased but people were still allowed
to share it so you could still share it
you could still consume it when i say
the distribution has decreased it got
shared how does that work basically the
ranking and news feed was a little bit
less so
fewer people saw it than would have
otherwise so it definitely by what
percentage i don't know off the top my
head but it's it's it's meaningful
i mean it's incredible so distribution
was decreased at first he says
uh distribution was decreased it was a
little bit then he says it was
meaningful at the end so you could share
it you could share the hunter biden
laptop story but if you share it and no
one's around to see it have you shared
it at all if a tree falls in the forest
you get it you see what they did so what
he's saying and he also says this thing
we don't want to we don't want to be in
charge of what's true and false so we go
to third party fact checkers well
surprise surprise all of their third
party track factor
fact checkers
fact [ __ ] are uh
they're all we know this they're all
left-wing activist organizations right
they're not going to anyone
right-leaning to ask what a fact is or
isn't so they're telling you
that oh we don't censor we let you post
things we just don't let people see it
right and this is what shadow banning is
this is on twitter when you know right i
used to be able to tweet out i could put
a picture i'd you know i could put a
picture of alf and a emoji of a banana
and it would get 10 000 retweets and now
people just don't see the tweets anymore
so they haven't censored me i'm still
tweeting there's just nobody there to
see it